i think they're going through
sort of an existential crisis about do
they want to be recognized by the
international community as being a
legitimate government the president of
the united states is now running cover
for the taliban so i guess we're the pr
wing for the taliban now that's exciting
the pentagon spokesperson by the way ned
price he can't or john kirby rather he
can't even say how many americans are
even in afghanistan at this point
how many americans american citizens
remain in
in afghanistan i don't know the state
department would be a better place to go
for an estimate of how many americans or
afghanistan or in and around kabul that
is not a figure that the united states
military
would would know and um and i think as
you also know not every american citizen
in another country uh uh that there's no
obligation that they
register their presence uh and and that
we and that you can have a perfect
accurate count okay in order to make
anybody believe that the administration
has any level of control the biden
administration has now been put in the
position of becoming the pr wing for the
taliban this is not a surprise you saw
that the the obama administration did
the exact same thing with iran obama
came into office wanting iran to be
established as a sort of regional power
for no reason at all because again he
had perverse foreign policy ideas that
made no sense in the real world and so
what this meant is he wanted to kind of
deal with taliban with with the iranians
so he lied to the american people and so
did ben rhodes his national security
advisor they just lied
they went out there and they said that
there was a moderate wing of the
iranians and we were emboldening the
moderate
wing of the iranian government and then
we spent years defending the iranian
government oh really they're moderate oh
really they're moderating oh really
they're getting better oh you know
they're really not so bad is there
anything really to worry about i mean
that like they're gonna get better guys
i mean they want to be legitimate
players on the world stage we became the
pr wing for the iranian mullahs even as
they fostered terrorism around the
region even as they murdered tens of
thousands of people in places like syria
and lebanon and yemen
even as they funded hamas
it was the united states and barack
obama's administration were
soft-peddling the evils of the iranian
regime now we're doing the exact same
thing with the taliban because you see
in order to make americans believe
everything is going to be okay in
afghanistan we have to believe that the
taliban are a different sort of taliban
maybe they're changing their stripes you
know no guarantees but maybe they're
going to be better this time around
now is there any evidence whatsoever
like at all that they're better this
time around they're literally just
shooting people they're going around and
hunting journalists
they pledged the same thing in 96 when
they first took over afghanistan that
they have now which is pardon for
everybody and then by pardon they mean
you will be dead i mean that's basically
what they mean but you've now turned the
white house of the united states into a
pr wing for the worst people on earth
the same way that obama did with the
iranians so here for example is the
president of the united states joe biden
saying you know
the taliban they're probably going
through some sort of existential crisis
right now you know they have to decide
whether they want to be part of the
international community here's the thing
they've already decided the answer is no
and they're not going through an
existential crisis the west is going
through an existential crisis because
the west has no idea what it believes
the west doesn't know what it stands for
aside from the evils of supposed
inherent white supremacy embedded in all
of our institutions and
transgenderism the west has basically
very few principles to which it is
certainly committed at this point we
don't know what we stand for we don't
know why we stand for the things we
stand for we are going through an
existential crisis the taliban are going
through a victory dance because a bunch
of regressive barbaric cavemen from the
8th century just defeated the most
powerful military in the history of the
world by the way for the second time
right because they did this to the
soviets in the 80s
so now they're they're proclaiming
victory on the exact same thing even
though really the two instances
shouldn't be comparable the united
states was holding the line in
afghanistan 2 500 troops the difference
is the taliban have a 1 000 year time
horizon and we have about a 20-year time
horizon in the united states we get
bored after 20 years and we're like oh
well this is an endless war you know
what endless war means to the taliban
you know what an endless war means to
the people in afghanistan afghanistan
has essentially been in a state of war
since at least 1979.
so an endless war to them does not look
like an endless war to us and so they
can declare victory after having their
asses kicked all over the map for 20
years because they outlasted us
okay but in any case joe biden has now
become the pr wing for the taliban this
is what he has to do now
i think they're going through
sort of an existential crisis about do
they want to be recognized
by the international communities being a
legitimate government
i'm not sure they do
but look they have they care about their
beliefs more well they do
but they also care about whether they
have food need
whether they have an income that can
make any money and run an economy they
care about whether or not they can hold
together the society that they in fact
say they care so much about
what an absolute joke the president of
the union and there he is they they want
legitimacy and some of the hamas wants
legitimacy guys it's all these terrorist
groups they just want legitimacy
the president of the united states is
now running cover for the taliban that's
the only thing you can take away from
that clip
i'm not sure that they want legitimacy
but you know they do want to make sure
that they can run the economy they want
to make sure i mean wouldn't they want
to be welcomed into the family of
nations by the way it's this exact same
sort of arrogance that led to a lot of
the nation-building project in the first
place they're just like us guys they
want to make sure that their that their
country still runs they have the same
priorities we do
john kirby at the pentagon was
specifically asked whether the biden
administration considers the taliban an
enemy now this should have a pretty
obvious answer
the answer is yes the taliban are the
worst people on the planet the taliban
are responsible for thousands of
american deaths the taliban are going
around murdering our allies yes they are
our enemy they've continued to be our
enemy but because joe biden just
surrendered to them he now has to say
that it's not a surrender by pretending
they're not our enemy so that's what
john kirby does here he just avoids the
question as to whether the taliban are
our enemy
does the us military con consider the
taliban an enemy
uh we're our focus right now uh the the
thing we're we're working against right
now is is time and space and we want to
get as many people out of kabul as we
can uh in as little amount of time as we
can that is called a not answer at all
the question was are the taliban our
enemy
the answer is we're trying to get
americans out
so i guess we're the pr wing for the
taliban now that's exciting in a second
we'll get to what joe biden's calculus
here is because it's pretty obvious what
his calculus is why he's doing all of
this and what his angle here is because
you look at this and i look at this and
we say this is the worst foreign policy
disaster of the last 40 years at least
since the fall of iran in 79
maybe since the end of world war ii
considering it's so self-inflicted i
mean at least when iran fell we really
had very little to do with it
when it comes to this we are the
complete cause of it
this is the i think it's the worst
foreign policy disaster for america
man i i honestly i i'm hard-pressed to
think of a worse foreign the end of
vietnam was not even as much of a
foreign policy disaster as this is
truly
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed